focus on things that need to move to  other people's desks so someone else is  waiting for an input from you then this  person is able to progress the work by  him or herself prioritize this make sure  you get this to this other person's desk  as quickly as possible because then you  can also expect to get the result back  rather quickly on significantly  increasing productivity of the whole  team next do things first that usually  lead to some quick wins to some quick  results it's often quite frustrating if  you receive a project a task maybe from  your leadership and you do some things  first where you know that only in one or  two or three days of work you can  actually have something presentable in  your hand and of course then if your  leadership reaches out to you after one  day ask what you have done and you don't  really have anything you can show for  that's awful not ideal